Speaker 1: OK, let's now get to the reaction
from a whole bunch of different people, including
Donald Trump himself, to the absolutely explosive
revelations, the claims being made in the
forthcoming book from Bob Woodward and Robert
Costa.
As we told you in an earlier segment, the
chairman of the Joint Chiefs, General Mark
Milley, was so worried that in the aftermath
of his loss to Joe Biden and the January 6th
riots, that Donald Trump was so out of it
that he would actually maybe try to launch
nuclear weapons.
And we learned about in the book, we learn
about the things that Mark Milley did in order
to try to prevent this, including having some
kind of failsafe type conversation with the
top military brass, phone call with China,
a phone call with Nancy Pelosi, et cetera.
Well, Donald Trump appeared on Newsmax yesterday
on the show of Sean Spicer, his own former
press secretary, and saying a lot of really
crazy things.
Let's just jump right into it.
Speaker 3: So, first of all, if it is actually
true, which is hard to believe that he would
have called China and done these things and
was willing to advise them of an attack or
in advance of an attack, that's treason.
Speaker 1: Now, it would only be advising
them in advance of an attack if this story
is true and Trump was really thinking of nuking
China.
I mean, understand now Trump in a moment will
deny it.
But think about what Trump is saying.
Trump is saying, you know, if we're doing
an operation, a military operation of some
kind, including a bombing, and you go and
you let the enemy know ahead of time, that's
treason.
But in order for that to be the case, you
have to be saying that it's true, which now
which Trump now says is not true anyway.
Speaker 3: And I would think I've had so many
calls today saying that's treason, number
one.
Number two, it's totally ridiculous.
I never thought of it.
You were there.
You were you knew what was happening in the
world.
Speaker 1: If you never thought of it, then
what Millie did made sense, which was assure
China that you're not actually about to nuke
them.
So which is it?
I mean, even the explanation is completely
incoherent,
Speaker 3: as you have plenty of friends.
You never heard the word China mentioned in
a thing like this.
You heard a lot of anger about China on trade
and we made a great trade deal.
You heard a lot of anger in China with the
China virus.
Speaker 1: The trade deal was a disaster.
There was no deal.
It was tariffs that were completely counterproductive,
remember, just to be thorough.
Speaker 3: But for them for him to say for
him to say that I would even think about attacking
China.
I think he's trying to just get out of his
incompetent withdrawal out of Afghanistan.
The worst.
The dumbest.
So remember,
Speaker 1: that was Trump's withdrawal plan,
first and foremost, Trump's withdrawal plan.
But if there was really no plan or even worry
that you were going to go after China, then
it's really no big deal for me to say, guys,
we're not going to nuke you.
We're not going to nuke you.
It's OK.
Don't worry.
So it's a it's a flip flopping.
Trump's furious for conflicting reasons, both
of which can't possibly be true
Speaker 3: thing that anybody seen probably
the most embarrassing thing that's ever happened
to our country where they they killed our
soldiers.
They were left with embarrassment.
Speaker 1: Now, Trump's on to Afghanistan,
by the way.
Speaker 3: We left Americans behind and we
left 85 billion dollars worth of the best
equipment in the world that I bought because
I was the one that rebuilt our military and
then Biden gave it.
That's a lie as well.
A way for him to say that I was going to attack
China is the most ridiculous thing I've ever
heard.
Speaker 1: And everybody so again, Millie
is not saying Trump was going to attack China.
Millie was saying we were worried he might
lash out and try to launch nukes.
But we believed we had a plan to prevent it
and we assuaged the fears of China.
It's like Trump Trump.
He's misunderstanding the story three different
ways and responding to it in three different
ways that are conflicts with each other.
Does he know it?
No.
The Sean Spicer know it or care?
Speaker 3: Probably not.
He knows it.
And I have to tell you, I don't know if they
have him on tape saying this, but I found
Woodward and I found his cohorts to be extremely
dishonorable people.
That's why I didn't do an interview with him.
I think he's highly overrated.
This guy is one of the most overrated guys.
He's a sleaze.
But I did not ever think of attacking China.
One other thing, I just read a report about
a week ago where they said Donald Trump was
the only president in decades that didn't
start a war.
Speaker 2: OK, so that
Speaker 1: often repeated phrase that out
of context and without any serious analysis
means very, very little.
So Trump, everybody's terrible.
The reporters are sleazes.
The general is a lightweight.
Note the constant ad hominem and attacks here,
Trump.
Drops in during the interview without evidence
that Obama is actually probably currently
in charge, not Joe
Speaker 3: Biden, he's the opposite.
He's worse than Obama.
Of course, Obama is probably running the government
now anyway, according to many.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So a former president saying it's actually
it's a different president, the president
that's officially the president.
It's not really the person that's in charge.
OK, that's this.
A former president saying it.
And then lastly here, here is Donald Trump
with a sort of completely delusional framing
of the perception of America's place in the
world.
Speaker 3: The people of our country respect
us.
They love our country and they want to see
our country succeed.
And our country has gone really downhill in
the last eight months like nobody's ever seen
before.
Now, remember,
Speaker 1: the polling is respect for America
globally is up basically everywhere.
Russians liked Trump.
I don't remember.
There's like one African country and then
also maybe Turkey, where Trump had like, OK,
approval and respect around the world.
Everybody else was disgusted by Trump.
Globally, respect for the world is up now
that Trump is gone.
It's the opposite of what Trump is telling
you.
Speaker 3: And you go to these elections that
are coming up in 22 and 24.
We're not going to have a country left.
The election was rigged and we're not going
to have a country left.
So a
Speaker 1: final lie.
They're as Donald Trump signs off.
So Trump highly triggered by this report,
which in all likelihood is true, at least
in the spirit, even if not every single detail
can be independently confirmed, that that's
sort of my sense of it.
The book is well cited and well researched.
And we're going to continue to learn more
about it.